Welcome friends. In this video we'll be running through a quick overview of setting up Dastardly
with Jenkins. Dastardly is a free lightweight web application security scanner for your CICD
pipelines. It is designed specifically for web developers and checks your application for seven
security issues that are likely to interest you during software development. Dastardly is
based on the same scanner as Burp Suite. You can integrate Dastardly with any CICD platform but
in this video we'll be configuring Dastardly to run in Jenkins. For Dastardly system requirements we
recommend a minimum of four CPU cores and four gigabytes of RAM. In this video we are testing
Dastardly with Jenkins build 2.375. Additionally your Jenkins server or build node must have docker
installed but no plugins beyond the Jenkins defaults are required to run Dastardly in a Jenkins CICD
pipeline. So let's begin. First within Jenkins we'll select a new item. We'll give this a name
Dastardly test. We'll select pipeline and click OK. Further we can give it a description here. We'll
jump right in and configure our pipeline. You can see we have two options. We can cut and paste the
script directly into Jenkins or we can pull that from an SCM which is what we're going to do. Just
a quick note on the script itself. This is available on our website documentation for Dastardly and it's
going to pull the latest image of Dastardly for you and the output for the Dastardly report will be an
XML format and here is where we can also specify the Dastardly target URL. This is the URL of the
application that we want to scan. For the purpose of this video we're going to be scanning Jinn and
Juice which is our deliberately vulnerable web application. Now I can continue configuring my
pipeline. I'm going to select git, add my credentials and the repository URL. Next I need to specify the
branch and for me that's going to be main and then my script path which is Jenkins file. Now I can save
and build my pipeline. If I select the pipeline I can monitor the progress of the scan in the console output.
We can see Dastardly has started and has begun its scan of our target application. Scans will run for no more than 10 minutes.
We'll fast forward here and we can check out the results.
Okay our scan is complete. We can see that the build has failed because we have located vulnerabilities within our application.
If we scroll back up to the top and select our build
we can then view our test results.
This will detail all failed tests for our particular build and we can select one to view the stack trace and this will give us detail on our particular vulnerability.
So we can see here we have a cross-site scripting found at this location.
We scroll into the stack trace. This is going to give us issue background information on that particular vulnerability.
Some remediation advice. We'll be able to view our evidence which includes the request and the response.
There will also be a reference to our web security academy. This will include additional detail on the particular vulnerability as well as a sandbox environment to carry out the same kind of attack.
And finally our vulnerability classifications.
And that's it folks. As simple as that.
You can check out our other dastardly docs to view configuration steps for running dastardly in TeamCity, GitHub Actions and our platform independent instructions.
Thank you and take care.
Thank you.